welcome back to cbs mornings we're
getting more reaction to las vegas
raiders head coach john gruden resigning
he stepped down amid reports he used
racist sexist and homophobic language in
a series of emails from 2010 to 2018. in
his resignation statement gruden said he
did not want to be a distraction for the
raiders he said he was sorry and never
meant to hurt anyone expatriates and
chiefs offensive lineman ryan o'callahan
is one of only few openly gay former nfl
players after coming out in 2017 he
wrote a note to his younger self for a
series note to self o'callaghan
described the pain of hiding his
sexuality while playing football
you're going to do everything in your
power to make sure no one finds out that
you're gay
you know that if your cover is blown
you'll lose everything
if you're gay you're as good as dead
you'll live 29 years of your life in
fear
you'll keep up this facade because you
think there is no alternative
powerful stuff after retiring from the
nfl ryan founded the rhino callahan
foundation to help other lgbtq athletes
he joins us for an exclusive broadcast
interview ryan good morning good morning
happy to be here thank you so let me ask
you what was your response to the emails
when you read all of that yeah when it
first came out i i looked into it and he
said some awful terrible things but what
i looked for initially was
something from john gruden i wanted to
hear what he had to say you know the
majority of these emails were a decade
ago and i'm the type of person that
believes in growth people change and
i wanted to hear specific things that
he has learned over the past decade why
his language was offensive you know
having carl
uh nasa the first openly gay player on
the team maybe that changed his
perspective about
uh lgbtq players but
he didn't have anything to say he just
you know up and
resigned um you know because of that
you know i'm sitting here the only thing
i can believe is that
he hasn't grown you know i was willing
to give him that that benefit of the
doubt because you know i regret things i
said a decade ago and i wouldn't want
those held against me because i'm a
different person
but we didn't get that from him and you
mentioned carl nasim who recently came
out and even gruden came out in support
of him as one of his players so you
believe if gruden would have came out
and owned up to it and said you know
what
that was years ago i'm not the same guy
i have a player on my roster who is gay
and we support him um you think it would
have been a different result
would he still have a job i think it
would have helped now he said a lot of
awful things about a lot of different
groups of people i think the nfl didn't
seem to be a one-off no it wasn't just
one thing a long time ago and the nfl
has come a long way in in the past
decade of trying to get in front of
these issues and actually
you know stand up for a lot of these
social justice things and even when it
wasn't popular and
it would be tough for them to have one
of their head coaches
who had said these things still be
employed it really wouldn't be a good
look so i don't know if he would have
been able to save his career
but just as a human being to come out
and and show growth i think would have
gone a long way yeah i look at your note
to self ryan uh that's where we first
met you and it it's so hard to hear you
say that at times you thought about
suicide because you knew that you
couldn't come out uh being a nfl player
do you think that the nfl has changed a
lot since then do you think it's more
open and more inclusive because you hear
emails like gruden's and you go well
has it changed how bad is it yeah
because he wasn't writing him he was
writing him to other nfl executives in
some cases he was but the nfl has a
governing body
i know they've changed i've sat across
the table from roger goodell and he's
asked me what can i do to help closeted
players and i've had these discussions
with it multiple times and
we've talked about different things
which they've then put into place and
like when carl came out the nfl was
ready
they wanted to have a better response
than what happened with you know michael
sam back in the day yes so they've taken
a lot of steps to
actually show they care and i feel
they're sincere about it some people say
this is part of cancel culture do you
see it that way
i don't only because he didn't even try
to fight it he had no defense he didn't
he didn't say you know that's not me
anymore you know so
you know if he would have stood up and
and
one own up to the awful things he said
and then talked about how he learned
from them and how he's not that person
anymore
i'd be more sympathetic to it but
because he didn't do any of that
i mean the other term for cancer culture
of course is accountability
yes we didn't hear gruden take account
for what he said we haven't heard much
from him at all he just sort of walked
away we spoke yesterday to bill uh
rhoden uh a writer sports writer uh who
talked about enablers uh gruden was
talking to a group of peers
locker rooms have cultures people say
things
how does the enabling get stopped how do
people intervene to prevent this sort of
culture from continuing i think it's a
lot easier when it's a peer-to-peer
coaching coach player to player to step
in and speak up when you hear something
that's not right but
you know for a player to
talk to your head coach about something
he said that would be more difficult but
i think players do do a good job even
back when i was playing of holding each
other accountable for the things they
say in the locker room
now i came in to know three i was
drafted by the minnesota vikings
and i can honestly say in my locker room
there wasn't homophobic slurs um being
thrown around
but my experience is different than
yours what was yours like yeah in high
school and college you had quite a bit
of that you know guys were younger and
mature but in the nfl i can't remember
one instance in the locker room of just
homophobic slurs people going on rants
it's interesting um there was a case of
a coach who would say things like no
homo which is arguably not as bad as
some of the things rudin said but still
not appropriate
but yeah i just like you i didn't have
that experience of my teammates saying
things do you think that there are a lot
of gay players in the nfl that cannot
come out or
still reluctant to come out in 2021 i
know quite a few you know quite a few
really yeah
what's it going to take
well i think carl kind of opened the
door for a lot of people you know when i
when i talk to closeted players the main
concerns are losing their job cultural
family
um and i think carl's
experience answered the question of can
you are you going to lose your job right
are they worried about the owners their
teammates or the fans
it's a societal problem too it's bigger
than sports it is the closet being in
the closet is a scary place you everyone
handles it differently but you build
this up in your mind to be something
that you don't think you can ever
conquer at least i did so
you know i don't
i don't know if it's an owners or a fan
thing but
um
you know i once again i think the nfl is
doing a good job of putting themselves
out there and saying hey you can come
out and there's a lot of owners who are
now doing things publicly to show their
support which is only going to help and
you've underscored you've underscored
something very important in this
conversation which is we have not heard
from gruden and we don't know if in his
mind he has moved on and is a different
person we want to hear what he thinks
about it today would be helpful to hear
it also good to hear that you had sat
down with roger dell who came to you and
said what can we do ryan it's so good to
see you again happy to see you joining
us
ryan's also a best-selling author just
saying by the way yeah oh by the by